يزور الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في اول رحله خارجيه له
منذ توليه منصبه نهايه الشهر الماضي ومن
المنتظر ان تناقش الزياره التي تاتي تلبيه
لدعوه العاهل السعودي عددا من الملفات
الثنائيه والاقليميه التي تهم
البلدين
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين ما الرساله التي يحملها اختيار
مرسي السعوديه محطه لاولى زياراته
الخارجيه وما اهم القضايا التي تنتظره
فيها وما مدى اهميه نتائج زياره مرسي
للسعوديه في الكشف عن معالم سياسته تجاه
القضايا الخليجيه والعربيه
الراهنه بعد اقل من اسبوعين على توليه
منصبه رسميا وفي خضم ملفات داخليه شديده
التفاعل والتعقيد اختار الرئيس المصري
محمد مرسي التوجه الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في زياره هي الاولى التي تحمله
خارج البلاد عدد من القضايا والملفات
الثنائيه والاقليميه ستكون حاضره في زياره
مرسي الى السعوديه لكن ولان بدت نتائج بحث
هذه القضايا والملفات مهمه في حد ذاتها
فانها تكتسب اهميه زائده كونها تعتبر من
الناحيه الاخرى مقياسا لقدره زائر جده على
تبديد شكوك طالما تراكمت بين دول الخليج
وحركه الاخوان المسلمين الحاضنه الفكريه
والتنظيميه التي جاء
منها محادثات مع المسؤولين السعوديين
واداء مناسك العمره ولقاء بالجاليه
المصريه كل ذلك في نحو 24
ساعه رغم قصر جوله الرئيس محمد مرسي فانها
تحمل ابعادا رمزيه وتنشط حسابات بعضها
قديم قبيل الزياره نشرت صحيفه سعوديه صوره
للشيخ الراحل حسن البنا يقبل يد الملك
الراحل عبد العزيز ال سعود فهم ذلك بانه
محاوله لتاكيد الرياده السعوديه لن تزعج
صوره مشهدا قوامه صور متتابعه من العلاقه
القديمه كانت صله الرياض بالاخوان
المسلمين بصفتهم جماعه محظوره وجد بعض
اعضائها ملاذا في السعوديه رغم الحساسيه
السلفيه الاخوانيه المتبادله تنافسا على
النفوذ جماعه اتهمت خليجيا بتاييد احتلال
الكويت عندما كانت الوشائج متينه بين
الرياض والقاهره في احد حسن مبارك كان
ينظر بعين الريبه الى التقارب بين جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وايران والان هل يمكن
تصور علاقه الرياض بالدوله المصريه من دون
مرورها بالجماعه التي بثق منها رئيس تلك
الدوله في الربيع الماضي اغلقت الرياض
سفرتها وقنصليات لها في مصر بعد مظاهرات
طالبت بالافراج عن محام مصري اعتقل في
السعوديه بتهمه حيازه ادويه يحضر تناولها
دون وصفه طبيه ذلك جزء من ملف ينتظر
الرئاسه المصريه المحبوسون في السعوديه
اضافه الى قضايا مليون ونصف المليون مهاجر
مصري اقتصاديا يتوقع ان يبعث مشروع الجسر
البحري بين البلدين بطول 50 كيلومترا وان
لا تنقص الاستثمارات السعوديه البالغه
حاليا 27 مليار دولار علما ان التبادل
التجاري وصل الى خه مليارات دولار بعد ان
كان مليارا و300 مليون فقط في
2005 اما على الصعيد الاقليمي فالاتفاق
اكبر طمان مرسي دول الخليج بان بلاده لا
تصدر الثورات الى احد وقال ان امن الخليج
خط احمر رساله احد مستقبليها ايران وبشان
الازمه السوريه يؤيد الطرفان طالب الشعب
السوري المنتفض لكن السعوديه ليست غافله
عن مستقبل يكون فيه الاخوان السوريون طرفا
اساسيا بعد اي تغيير محتمل ومناقشه هذا
الموضوع معنا من القاهره الدكتور عمر دراج
مسؤول العلاقات الخارجيه في حزب الحريه
والعداله وايضا من الرياض الدكتور خالد
الدخيل الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي السعودي
اهلا بكما ابدا معك دكتور دراج ما الرساله
التي تحملها هذه الزياره الاولى لمحمد
مرسي الى
السعوديه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم زي ما
حضرتك ذكرت في المقدمه هي زياره تاتي في
وقت بالغ الاهميه هذه اول زياره خارجيه
يقوم بها الدكتور محمد مرسي اللي هو يعتبر
اول رئيس مصري منتخب انتخابا حرا نزيها
شفافا من الشعب المصري في عقاب الثوره
المصريه بعد عهود طويله من غياب هذه
العمليه
الديمقراطيه يعني عندما تكون المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي اول حطه يعني خارجيه
للرئيس المصري المنتخب فهذه رساله واضحه
توضح اهميه العلاقات السعوديه المصريه
سواء بالنسبه للاداره المصريه الجديده او
بالنسبه للشعب المصري بوجه
عام يعني لا يمكن افال هذا التوقيت اطلاقا
رغم الانشغال الشديد للدكتور مرسي وللرئيس
في الملفات الداخليه الملتهبه موجوده
حاليا لكن ذلك لم يمنعه من تلبيه الدعوه
الكريمه التي ارسلها اليه شقيقه الملك
شقيقه الملك عبد الله دكتور الدخيل كيف
تفهم السعوديه هذه الخطوه من قبل الرئيس
المصري
الجديد انا اعتقد انه طبعا انا لا اتكلم
بال عن الجانب الرسمي لكن اتصور انها
مفهومه في السعوديه انها زياره طبيعيه
وتؤكد
علاقات طويله جدا بين السعوديه وبين مصر
الحقيقه فيما يتعلق بالسعوديه ومصر
تحديدا هم الدولتان العربيتان الكبيرتان
الوحيدتان التي تتمتع كل منهما في هذه
المرحله المضطربه بدوله متماسكه وبا
استقرار
سياسي المنطقه في حاجه ماسه جدا الى تطوير
وتفاهم سعودي مصري لضبط الاوضاع في
المنطقه مصر في حاجه الى السعوديه
والسعوديه في حاجه الى مصر خاصه في هذه
المرحله العالم العربي كما تعرفين الان
يمر بمرحله انتقاليه مضطربه
سوف تتحقق نتيجه
لها تغيرات
كبيره سواء فيما يتعلق بالدول فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات الاقليميه والتحالفات على مستوى
المنطقه يعني دول كبيره الان مثل سوريا
والعراق واليمن والسودان مضطربه بشكل
مخيف وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه التفاهم
السعودي المصري في هذه المرحله ضروري في
مصلحه المنطقه وفي مصلحه السعوديه ومصر
بدون ان ندخل في التفاصيل مع بدايه الحديث
حاليا صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز مثلا قالت
انها رساله لتبديد المخاوف التي نشات من
جراء الشكوك بان هناك تعاونا ما بين حركه
الاخوان المسلمين التي انبثق منها الدكتور
مرسي وبعض الحركات الاسلاميه المعارضه في
منطقه الخليج ما
رايك لا ما اعتقد اعتقد انه قضيه العلاقه
بين مصر او بين الاخوان تحديدا وبين
السعوديه ودول الخليج دخلها كثير جدا من
الاشاعات والكثير من سوء الفهم هناك
اختلافات لا شك كانت موجوده وهي خلافات
نشات في الاساس في تسعينيات القرن الماضي
لكن يجب ان نتذكر ان العلاقات السعوديه مع
الاخوان مرت بمراحل ثلاث والان تدخل
المرحله الرابعه كانت علاقات متميزه في
اربعينيات وخمسينيات القرن الماضي وكانت
علاقات متميزه في ستينيات وسبعينيات القرن
الماضي المرحله الثالثه هي مرحله
التسعينات نحن الان ندخل المرحله الرابعه
وهي مرحله يتولى فيها الاخوان رئاسه
الجمهوريه والاغلبيه في البرلمان على
الاقل المنحل فبالتالي نحن امام مرحله
جديده الاخوان سيكون لهم موقف مختلف عما
كان موقفهم عندما كانوا في المعارضه لاكثر
من 80
سنه ال المنطقه تغيرت العالم تغير الدول
تغيرت لا يجب ان نبني الرؤيه لهذه
العلاقات على اساس ما كان في الماضي انا
اتصور انه يجب ان نتجه الى المستقبل دكتور
دراج هل توافق دكتور الدخيل الراي بان
العلاقات الان يجب ان تتغير عما كانت عليه
في الماضي لا سما في التسعينيات هل سيكون
موقف الاخوان مختلف عنما كان عليه عندما
كان لا يزال في
المعارضه انا والله اتفق مع تقريبا كل ما
ذكر دكتور الخيل
ا نحن الان عندما نتحدث عن العلاقه بين
مصر والمملكه العربيه السعوديه لا نتحدث
عنها بصفتها علاقه فقط ما بين الاخوان
المسلمين والمملكه العربيه السعوديه نحن
الان نتحدث عن رئيس مصري يعني على قمه او
على راس هرم السلطه التنفيذيه في مصر
وبالتالي السياسه التي سينتهجها والعلاقات
التي سيبنها مع مختلف دول العالم وعلى
راسها طبعا المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي
يعني علاقه تعبر عن مصالح واهتمامات
الدوله المصريه وليس مصالح واهتمامات
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين او اي جماعه او
حزب اخر او حزب الحريه والعداله الذي يعني
نشا منه الرئيس ولكن نحن نتكلم الان عن
مؤسسه الرئاسه وعن الدوله المصريه بشكل
عام وانا يعني اوضح ان انا يعني حقيقه انا
مسؤول في حزب الحريه والعداله ولكني لا لا
تتحدث ايضا باسم مؤسسه الرئاسه لانه
الرئيس محمد مرسي الان هو رئيس لكل
المصريين ويعبر اساسا عن التوجهات العامه
للدوله المصريه بشكل عام واضح ان هذه
التوجهات هي توجهات تضع العلاقه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على راس
اولوياتها بدليل ان هذه الزياره هي زياره
زي ما ذكرت اول زياره خارجيه لرئيس مصري
المنتخب
وبالتالي فهذا هو المنظور الحقيقه الذي
يجب ان او ينبغي ان
ننظر من خلاله الى هذه العلاقه سواء كان
في الاخوان المسلمين في الصوره في العلاقه
او او لا يكون في صوره الاخوان او حزب
الحريه والعداله هم احد الاحزاب واحد ال
والاخوان احد التنظيمات الشعبيه اللي
موجوده في مصر
والعلاقات الشعبيه ان شاء الله سوف تكون
انا متصور انها تكون على مستوى عالي لانه
النظام مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه بشكل
خاص ومع دول الخليج بشكل عام لانه الحقيقه
كان في مشكله ان النظام السابق في مصر كان
بينته سياسه تخويف وتوزيع ا للعالم كله
وسواء للداخل في مصر او خارج مصر في الدول
العربيه او في شتى انحاء العالم من
الاسلاميين بشكل عام وكان كثير من
الانطباعات
الخاطئه يعني هل يذهب ليصح هذه
الطباعات انا بدون شك لانه هذه الانطباعات
مبنيه اصلا على معلومات خاطئه كان بينته
جها النظام المصري السابق لكي يعني يضمن
بقاه على هرم السلطه وكان يعني يستخدم
سياسه التخويف والت التفزيع هذه لكي يعني
يعني يضمن بقاء المعارضه الاسلاميه اللي
هي انشط حركات المعارضه في مصر بعيدا عن
اي نفوذ او اي علاقات ايجابيه مع اي من
دول العالم او حتى عن الداخل المصري
سنناقش كيف سيصحح هذه الانطباعات والى اي
حد ستعكس نتائج زياره مرسي للسعوديه معالم
سياسته الخارجيه على المستويين الخليجي
والعربي ككل ولكن بعد فاصل قصير فابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
علاقات مصر بالخليج والعالم العربي في
الفتره المقبله دكتور الدخيل كيف
يمكن للرئيس المصري الجديد ان يصحح
الانطباعات كما اشار الدكتور ضيفي من مصر
قبل قليل الدكتور دراج لا سما لجهه ان
النظام السابق فتره مبارك
اخاف العالم كله تقريبا من الاسلاميين ومن
حركه الاخوان المسلمين
بالتحديد لا طبعا بس خليني فقط اكد على
كلمه قالها الدكتور الراج وهي
انه الرئيس مرسي اول رئيس للجمهوريه
الثانيه في مصر
جاء يعني من خلال اول انتخابات في
مصر وجاء الى الحكم باسم الثوره وبعد 10
ايام من ادائه القسم
في اول زياره له خارجيه الى السعوديه
اعتقد انه هذا الشيء بحد ذاته مقدر بشكل
كبير يعني في السعوديه على المستوين
الرسمي
والشعبي اما بالنسبه للخلافات نحن الان
نتكلم على قيادات
سياسيه اثناء حكم الرئيس حسني
مبارك كان الاخوان حركه تنتمي للاسلام
السياسي والخلاف اللي
موجود بين الاخوان وبين السعوديين
والخليجيين هو خلاف بين حركات اسلاميه
بشكل اساسي له طابع ديني وهذه الخلافات
سوف
تبقى لكن هذا ليست المشكله هنا ان يبقى في
خ يعني خلافات على المستوى الديني هذه
الخلافات على المستوى الديني ستبقى
تقصد اي طبعا ممكن تبقى لانه لانه
السلفيين دائما هناك مسافه بين السلفيين
وبين الاخوان داخل مصر
وخارج مصر ولكن دكتور دراج اشار الى نقطه
مهمه دكتور في ايضاحه ان الرئيس محمد مرسي
يزول سعوديه فقط لتوضيح هذه النقطه يزور
السعوديه ليس كممثل لحزب الحريه والعداله
او الاخوان المسلمين وانما كرئيس لدوله
مصر يمثل مصالح مصر وليس مصالح حزب او فئه
معينه حتى ولو انتمى هو
اليها هذا اللي اردت انا انا كنت ساصل الى
هذه النقطه ان هناك المستوى السياسي وهوو
المهم وجود خلافات على المستوى الديني
ليست ليست هذه المشكله الاشكاليه في كيفيه
اداره هذا الخلاف وان نتعايش مع هذه
الاختلافات الرئيس حسني ياتي كرئيس لمصر
حاليا وليس كعضو في جماعه الاخوان و كما
اشر الدكتور دراج وليس كرئيس لحزب العداله
والحريه ولو انه لا يضيره ان يكون رئيس
لحزب العداله والحريه الرئيس اوباما في
الولايات المتحده هو يمثل الحزب
الديمقراطي لا يمثل حزب الجمهور مثلا ف
بالتالي على المستوى
السياسي قد تبقى هناك خلافات ثانويه او
اختلافات ثانويه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
الاقليميه لكن اعتقد على المستوى الثنائي
وعلى المستوى الاستراتيجي هناك مجال كبير
جدا للتعاون السعودي المصري سواء من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه او من الناحيه الامنيه
او من الناحيه الاقليميه في المنطقه هناك
الملف السوري هناك ملف القضيه الفلسطينيه
هناك ملف الخليج العربي هناك الملف
الايراني هناك قضايا كثيره بالنسبه لملف
الخليج والانتقادات بالنسبه لملف
الخليج الانتقادات التي صدرت من ضحي خلفان
من الامارات واثارت ضجه كبيره وجدلا برايك
هل سيتم احتوائها في
السعوديه انا ما اعتقد انه ما قاله ضاحي
خلفان له تاثير على الموقف السعودي لا
الشعبي الرسمي او السؤال الى اي حد يمثل
موقف
خلفان موقف دوله الامارات هل هو يعبر كما
قيل عن رايه الشخصي ام يعبر عن سياسه
رسميه لكن هذا الشيء مختلف رسميا هم اوضح
الموضوع علاقه السعوديه به رسميا اوضحوا
الموضوع انا اسالك عن الخلفيه يعني بشكل
عام رسميا في الامارات اوضحوا الموضوع لكن
انا اسالك بشكل عام الى اي حد يمكن ان
يمثل ربما رايا عاما غير معلن لدى فئات
كبيره لكن معلن عنده
هو طبعا هناك راي عام في السعوديه كما في
مصر كما في الخليج من الاخوان وهذا لن
يختفي بين ليله
وضحاها وهذا يحتاج الى وقت الاخوان الان
الحقيقه يتم محاكمه اعتقد موقفهم ويتم
محاكمه سياساتهم وهم لسه لم يمضوا في
الرئاسه ل عش ايام اها انا ارى انه يجب ان
يعطى الاخوان الفرصه الفرصه كامله لان
يمارسوا الحكم وان يثبتوا جدارتهم وان
يثبتوا قيادتهم لمصر وان يثبتوا التزامهم
بقيم الثوره وبالدم قراطيه والانتخابات
اذا نجحوا في هذا عندها يمكن الحكم لان
الامور بنتائجها ليس هناك داعي لاستباق
مواقف او لاصدار مواقف على تجربه لا تزال
في ايامها الاولى ا دكتور دراج اذا بحسب
دكتور الخيل لا زال الامر تحت الاختبار ما
الذي يمكن ان يقدمه او ان يقوله الدكتور
مرسي لكي يعني يكون في هذا الاختبار ناجحا
ولو هو في فتره بدايه
الامر
اي انا اؤكد على ما ذكرت سابقا وذكره ايضا
الدكتور الدخيل ان الدكتور مرسي يمثل
الشعب المصري باكمال وليس فقط الاخوان
المسلمين
ولكن مجرد ا يعني يعني هذه الزياره القيام
بها لكي تكون اول زياره خارجيه هو يعني هي
رساله واضحه جدا كما يعني ذكرت انا وضيفك
الكريم قبل ذلك بالاضافه الى ذلك سوف يتم
التاكيد انا متاكد من وقع يعني معرفتي
بالدكتور محمد مرسي ان هو كان مسؤول كان
رئيس حزب الحريه والعداله وكان هو المسؤول
الاول عن
البرنامج السياسي من الناحيه الخارجيه
بالنسبه للحزب وكان متداخل جدا في كل وضع
الاستراتيجيات الخارجيه للحزب فانا عارف
جيدا انه مهتم جدا بعلاقات مصر بالخليج
العربي باقامه علاقات قويه متوازنه تقوم
على الاخوه وتقوم على التون والمصالح
المشتركه وتقوم هذا ذكرته في بدايه
الحللقه واصبح واضحا مثلا
هل سيفتح موضوع المحامي المصري
احمد الجزاوي المعتقل في
السعوديه انا ليس لي علم بالمواضيع التي
سوف يعني يقوم الدكتور مرسي باثارتها زي
ما ذكرت لحضرتك انه نحن الان كحزب حريه
وعداله بعيدون عن مؤسسه الرئاسه يعني
الرئيس يعني بدا هذه المرحله معه عدد قليل
من المعاونين لم يشكل الحكومه بعد
وبالتالي احنا كمؤسسه حزبيه لسنا يعني
متداخلين بشكل كبير مع الدكتور مرسي على
الاقل في هذه المرحله ولكني اعلم ان
الدكتور مرسي حريص جدا على متانه وقوه
العلاقه مع المملكه السعوديه وفي نفس
الوقت ايضا طبعا حريص على ابناء مصر
الموجودين في كل بلاد العالم ومنها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سواء منهم اكثر
من مليون ونصف مصري يعملون بجد واجتهاد في
تكريس وترسيخ نهضه المملكه بالاضافه الى
بعض ابناء مصر سواء المتهمين في قضايا او
عليهم احكام
معينه لا الدكتور مرسي من من من المبادئ
الاساسيه عنده هو احترام القانون اذا كان
هناك اي شيء قانوني يجرم عليه اشخاص طبقا
لقرائن وطبقا لاحكام قضائيه بته فلا يمكن
اطلاقا ان هو يثير هذا يثير هذه المواضيع
اما اذا كان هناك مجال للاستفسار عن احوال
المصريين الموجودين هناك على ذمه قضاء و
على ذمه احداث معينه فيعني اكيد من واجب
الدكتور مرسي كرئيس للمصريين ان يسال عن
احوال هؤلاء واطمئن عن موقفهم القانوني
ساعود اليه لاسالك عن مساله سياسته
الخارجيه في العالم الخليجي والعربي بشكل
اوسع ولكن قبل ذلك دكتور دخيل في حال فتح
هذا الملف للنقاش المصريين المحبوسين في
السعوديه هل تتوقع ان تكون نتيجه فتح هذا
الملف ايجابيه
مثلا
انا يعني الحقيقه لا افهم هذه قضايا
جانبيه لانه قضايا انه متهمين في بلدان في
متهمين سعودين ولكن مثلا المحامي المصري
اثار يعني مشكله كبيره وتوتر دبلوماسي بين
البلدين ولهذا س معلش انا اعرف بس بس ايضا
جاء سبقا ان فتح هذا الملف مع مع الوفد
الرسمي والشعبي الذي جاء الى المملكه قبل
حوالي اكثر من شهر ونص تقريبا فتح هذا
الملف وفي تصور انه تمت انا ما عندي
معلومات الحقيقه تفصيليه عن الموضوع لكن
بما ان الوفد جاء لابد انه فتح ولا بد ان
تم تم التفاهم على هذا الشيء هذا كان قضيه
الحقيقه يعني اثيرت بطريقه خاطئه لا تخدم
البلدين تماما كان كان من الممكن التاكد
ومتابعتها بشكل قانون انارتها سياسيا هذا
صحيح مل اخ في ملف اخر ايضا ملف يعتبر
ساخن تحدثنا عن مساله المصريين هناك عن
البعد الاقتصادي للزياره الاستراتيجي يذهب
كرئيس لدوله وليس كرئيس لحزب اريد ان اسال
عن الملفات العربيه تحدثنا عن الامارات عن
الخليج اريد ان اسال عن الازمه السوريه
مثلا ما هي الرؤيه المشتركه التي يمكن ان
تجمع مصر حاليا والسعوديه على حل ممكن
للازمه
السوريه والله انا سبق ان استمعت الى
الرئيس
مرسي قبل
الانتخابات وكانت تصريحاته قويه جدا في
مناصره الشعب السوري وفي الوقوف مع ثوره
الشعب السوري وانا في تصوري تماما انه
هناك تلاقي كبير بين السعوديه ومصر حول
الملف
السوري فبالتالي ما يعني ربما لك اي مشكله
طيب دكتور
دراج ربما يعني ربما في الاليات و في
التفاصيل لكن من حيث الموقف الرئيسي من
الثوره في من الملف السوري اعتقد انه
السعوديين مع المصريين متقاربين جدا حول
هذا الموضوع دكتور دراج بالنسبه للملف
الايراني هو قام بهذه الزياره قبل ان يذهب
في رحله مقبله الى ايران الى اي حد تعكس
هذه الزياره واختياره للسعوديه يعكس فعلا
سياسته الخارجيه تجاه التي تبدا في العالم
العربي والخليجي
تحديدا هو موضوع زياره ايران ده هذا لم
يتقرر بعد يعني هذا موضوع يمكن مطروح من
خلال قمه دول عدم الانحياز لكن هذا لم
يتقرر بعد ولم يعلن اذا كان سيشارك
الدكتور مرسي في هذه الزياره اه لكن لكن
احنا بالنس بالنسبه لايران او باي بالنسبه
لاي دوله من دول العالم السياسه الخارجيه
لمصر بعد الثوره وكما نتبناه نحن في حزب
الحريه والعداله تقوم على العلاقات
المتوازنه مع كل دول العالم تقوم
على يعني التخلص من اي منازعات تكون
موجوده ممكن ان تكون موجوده بدون داعي
وبدون اي اسباب حقيقيه موضوعيه لوجود مثل
هذه النزاعات والصراعات لكن من الواضح انه
ذهاب الدكتور مرسي الى الم المك العربيه
السعوديه في هذا التوقيت وتصريحه قبل ذلك
ان امن الخليج هو خط احمر يعطي اشاره قويه
ان
يعني يعني اين تقف
مصر مصر الحقيقه وخاصه بعد الثوره انا
اتمنى ان الاخوه في الخليج يعني يدركوا
تماما انها اضافه حقيقيه للامن القومي
بالنسبه لدول الخليج وصلت فكرتك نحن نعم
يا فندم وصلت شكرا جزيلا دكتور عمرو
الدراج مسؤول علاقات الخارجيه في حزب
الحريه والعداله ايضا شكرا جزيلا من
الرياض دكتور خالد داخيل الاكاديمي والبحث
السياسي
السعودي بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
ه